wer mit einem carsharing fahrzeug oft
schnell fährt um zeit zu sparen braucht
sich nicht zu wundern wenn ihm mit der
kündigung des vertrages gedroht wird die
vernetzten wagen wissen nämlich ganz
genau wer wann wie schnell fährt sie
zeichnen es auf und schicken die daten
der zentrale stellt deren software dann
einzupacken fahrstil fest so ist es
zumindest schon passiert wird ein
mahnschreiben verschickt willkommen in
der zukunft was auto sonst alles noch
auszeichnen wies und sogar ins gefängnis
bringen kann das jetzt in klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
am liebsten würde ich mal einen
einspieler so ein video für verstehen
sie spaß produzieren am steuer sitzt ein
prominentes opfer
man schaltet eine ampel so blöd dass er
bei rot über die ampel fahren muss keine
andere wahl hat einfach so schon
entscheiden und danach schickt ihnen das
navigationsgerät automatisch zu einer
polizeistreife
er wird ganz schön blöd aus der wäsche
gucken aber so absurd ist dieser gedanke
allerdings gar nicht denn die modernen
autos sind mit so viel elektronik
vollgestopft und zudem immer online
da ist es ein leichtes mit
verkehrssündern umzugehen und fast ist
es schon realität geworden am markt kam
jedenfalls wegen der erfassten daten
seines 35 fahrzeugs ins gefängnis
allerdings auch gerechtfertigt mit den
daten konnte ihm nachgewiesen werden
dass er bei einem zusammenstoß viel zu
schnell mit dem geliehenen auto
unterwegs war dabei kam ein
unbeteiligter radfahrer ums leben aber
man bot musste für knapp drei jahre ins
gefängnis drivenow behauptete damals
zwar dass die daten erst für den prozess
mit denen des kunden verknüpft worden
wer aber schon mal ein mahnschreiben von
dem carsharing dienstleister bekommen
hat der dürfte da wahrscheinlich einen
etwas anderen eindruck haben weil im
test der stiftung warentest kam jetzt
heraus dass alle getestet mit den autos
verbundenen apps für android und ios
denn nur bei den apps kann man das
überhaupt checken viel mehr und vor
allem personenbezogene daten an die
autohersteller
geschickt wurden als sie eigentlich
dürften da landeten zum beispiel die
fahrzeugidentifikationsnummer zusammen
mit dem standort des autos beim
autohersteller
es ist überhaupt nicht ersichtlich wofür
der hersteller diese informationen
braucht exakte bewegungsprofile können
damit erzielt werden da wird dann der
gläserne bürger ausgerechnet über sein
eigenes auto ermöglicht und vor allem
klärte keiner der fahrzeughersteller
vorher die kunden umfassend und
verständlich über seine daten sammelwut
auf und das muss er aufgrund von
bundesdatenschutz und telemediengesetz
machen am krassesten war übrigens die
sammelwut von tesla achtung tesla
sammelt überall und verknüpft fleißig
die daten von öffentlichen datenbanken
werkstätten sozialen medien und
marketing firmen noch schlimmer über
fernzugriff sammelt tesla unter anderem
über die bordkameras daten zum fahrstil
und übergibt bei dienstwagen
die firma des angestellten oder auch an
behörden von sich aus rott ich bin hier
ansonsten einen riesen tesla in massen
basics und so weiter ferne
aber naja es zeigt sich auf jeden fall
hier muss besser kontrolliert werden und
den autoherstellern ganz genau auf die
finger geguckt werden
ich bin jedenfalls froh dass ich nicht
für jedes falschparken blechen muss der
welt schnell ihr wachstum halte ich
natürlich auf dem laufenden
zum thema datenschutz und wenn ihr kein
video dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
genau auf die leute hier geht es weiter
mit bakterien als datenspeicher hammer
thema also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran